two years after the murder of
13-year-old Tristan Bailey her family
had a chance to address her killer in a
Florida courtroom now sixteen-year-old
Aidan fucci faces 40 years to life in
prison after he entered a guilty plea in
the gruesome stabbing death of Bailey on
Mother's day in 2021 Bailey was
originally reported as a missing person
before a jogger ultimately found her
body in his first interview with police
fucci said he only pushed Bailey causing
her to fall down but the medical
examiner found that she had been stabbed
more than 100 times and part of the
murder weapon was actually broken off in
her skull during sentencing and me said
that defensive wounds on her arms and
hands showed that she was fighting for
her life the prosecution also called a
psychologist who said Fuji detailed a
hypothetical murder to his peers before
Bailey's death suggesting possible
premeditation Victim Impact statements
finished off the state's case on a very
powerful note and in defense's case
Fuji's grandmother also also addressed
Bailey's Family take a listen
114.
this jar now holds 114 Stones one for
each of the 114 stab wounds that my
sister had to endure the number of
questions I have for Aidan fucci
surrounding that night plagued my mind
did she see you coming at her with the
knife
or did you stab her well she wasn't
paying attention
did she scream out for help or was she
paralyzed with agony
did she cry for my mother
did she beg you to stop
did you hear her lungs gargling with
blood
or did you see it in her face when she
realized she could no longer breathe due
to her collapsed lungs
what were her last words
did you stay to watch her die
or did you leave her there in agonizing
pain as you ran away please
decision on May 9th 2021 and took the
very life that I brought into this world
please do not for one second think that
he could be rehabilitated at any point
he is beyond saving I just don't want to
say to the family I'm so sorry I wish I
could change when it happened and um
we pray for you every day
I pray for my family every day
and um I just find hope that you find
peace somewhere and
and uh just know that he has a good
family we miss him and we lost a child
too
wow you know Brian it's every Victim
Impact statement's difficult and
Powerful but do you think there's anyone
that stands out to you that may weigh
especially on the judge
I I honestly wanted to pick one I wanted
to say that no parents no mother should
bury a child it's it's it shouldn't
happen I wanted to say that the sisters
use of questions about wanting to know
about her sisters final moments would
have been the one or the medical
examiner recounting the 114 stab wounds
and how her last moments would have been
or the fact that part of the murder
weapon was still stuck in her body as he
callously walked away or the fact that
he supposedly planned this with uh or a
type of murder and I wanted to pick one
but no there is no one they all weigh
heavily on the hearts of anyone who
listens to this and I think it's going
to weigh heavily on the judge well that
was my question Nema I mean clearly this
is important for all of them to be able
to speak out but how much does it
actually play into a judge's decision
because doesn't the judge already have a
sentence in mind
I think does especially in a case like
this where you have a guilty plea so
normally you have your you know guilt in
your penalty phase right but in a case
like this you jump straight to the
Penalty phase he pled guilty he admitted
to the first degree murder that
premeditated murder it kind of reminds
me of Nicholas Cruz also there in
Florida Parkland school shooter where
you have this sort of elongated
sentencing phase where a lot of these
gruesome facts about the murder are
going to come out that typically don't
come out in a penalty phase because you
deal with it in the guild phase and I
think the judge is going to not only
focus on the fact that Brian talked
about but those selfies in the police
car afterwards I mean that's pretty
gruesome stuff yeah the callous nature
of that and all this attack
when we come back does freedom of speech
mean the freedom to mock well that's
what one dog toy company says it's in
their fight against a whiskey making
giant up next we're going to explain the
bizarre Supreme Court case
[Music]
and welcome back everybody so we end
Today's Show at the United States
Supreme Court which has decided some of
the most important legal matters in our
country and on Wednesday the court heard
a different kind of case in a showdown
between Jack Daniels and bad spaniels
that's right the whiskey company is
suing dog toy manufacturer VIP Products
LLC for allegedly violating Federal
trademark law you see the dog toy
version of the alcoholic beverage is
part of vip's silly squeakers line made
to resemble real life products the Jack
Daniels bottle has old number seven
Tennessee sour mash whiskey beneath its
trademark name while the bad spaniels
toy version says the old number two on
your Tennessee carpet now the district
court originally thought that this spin
on the whiskey bottle could actually
confuse consumers but VIP ended up
winning their appellate case so now the
Supreme Court is going to have to
determine if third-party humorous use of
a Brand's logo violates Federal
trademark law
deserves protection under the First
Amendment so neima I'll start with you
what did you think of Jack Daniel's
argument that VIP is misleading
consumers and using Jack Daniel's good
name one's a liquor company the other's
for dog toys not the easiest case
not the easiest case but you know when
you're dealing with these types of
trademarks intellectual property lawyers
tell you you gotta police and protect
your mark That's why Jack Daniels is
talking about that likelihood of
confusion of course we all know as
lawyers that's the legal standard here
but really is anyone going to be
confused here this is clearly a parody I
don't expect Jack Daniels to get into
the dog toy business so I would side
with the uh the defendants here
obviously the appellants and probably
rule against Jack Daniels if I were the
judge ruling on this one I'm just going
to present the counter argument there
that might be somewhere they expand you
know different merchandise it's
commercial they're selling a product
it's not like it's just a parody it's
not like it's just they're doing it in
his editorial fun they are selling
something here now Brian I'll turn it to
you VIP says they're protected by the
first amendment that isn't a trademark
issue so what about the freedom to mock
is that a strong argument I like it
because it moves the argument away from
a field that they probably don't want to
be in and that that this is a trademark
issue that the likeness of the toy is so
close to that of the actual bottle even
though there is a bad spaniel there's a
dog it's number three instead of seven
all the little intricacies that we
whiskey drinkers know we typically see
From a Jack Daniels bottle
I think it is a is a mockery it's a joke
it's a parody it's fake everything and
so I think that argument and separating
himself from a trademark makes it
stronger for them to say there are other
case laws whether it be spoken um
product you bring up a good point the
commercialness of it does change it it's
not just some late night TV show making
a joke about it but I think it brings
them into the realm where they have a
stronger argument that this is a joke
and not just a commercial product a lot
of people don't know this uh I used to
practice trademark law I think there's
some consumer confusion there I think I
could see the argument but that's my
take Nema Brian thank you both so much
everyone out there thanks for joining us
here on Long crime daily we are going to
see you next time as we discuss Justice
in America
foreign